new DC head James Gunn has announced an
impressive slate of new movies including
two different Superman films so why do
neither of them star Henry Cavill the
spider world just keeps on growing as in
April 2022 the movie studio went to
cinemacon and announced the arrival of
el nuerto slated to hit theaters on
January 12 2024. El muerto is a
super-powered wrestler who gets to
strength and speed from a magical mask
passed down from his dad of course
keeping said mask involves doing battle
with the supernatural Luchador called El
Dorado it hasn't been confirmed that El
Dorado will show up in the film nor do
we know of el nuerto will try to unmask
Spider-Man as he does in the comics
however it's been announced that bad
bunny will be putting on the Lucha Libre
mask in the upcoming film The Rapper and
actor told deadline I grew up watching
wrestling and I'm a wrestler I'm a
former Champion so this is why I love
this character I think it's the perfect
role to me and it will be epic monos
cueron the filmmaker behind 2015's
desiarto and the son of the legendary
Alfonso cueron will direct from a script
by Blue Beetle screenwriter Gareth
donate alcohol in 2000 2019 collider
revealed that Matt sazama and Burke
sharpless the duo behind Sony's morbius
has been hired to pen a screenplay based
on Marvel's Cassandra Webb AKA Madame
Webb The Clairvoyant character who made
her comic book debut in 1980s Amazing
Spider-Man number 210 was born blind and
suffers from a neurological condition
that can make tasks like moving and even
breathing extremely challenging hence
the spider web-shaped life support
system she's constantly hooked up to as
her condition worsens however Webb finds
herself developing powerful psychic
abilities she uses these Newfound powers
to become a medium though he's initially
skeptical Spider-Man himself comes to
trust her predictions it appears as
though the on-screen version of this
Madam web will be significantly younger
than the original but 50 Shades of Gray
star Dakota Johnson reportedly tapped to
play the character a huge age gap
between Johnson and the character
created by Dennis O'Neil and John romita
Jr became a Hot Topic on Twitter though
there was a younger version of Madame
Webb and the Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon
we'll find out how Johnson does in the
role when Madam Webb hits screens on
February 16 2024. it's pretty cool to be
in the Marvel World especially with a
character that's not so known the final
episode of the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier aired on April 23 2021 that same
day The Hollywood Reporter revealed that
Malcolm Spellman the show's Creator and
head writer was staying on at Marvel to
develop a fourth Captain America movie
one that's now titled New World Order
the film will follow the story of Sam
Wilson Steve Rogers hand-picked
successor for the Star-Spangled mantle
Spellman is co-pending the screenplay
with the Falcon in the Winter Soldier
staff writer Dallin moosen a relative
newcomer whose only previous
feature-length writing credit is the
2019 Sci-Fi Action sequel Iron Sky the
coming race as for who's directing
Julius Ona most famous for the
Cloverfield Paradox we'll be calling the
shots throughout the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier Sam grappled with the
historical and personal implications of
picking up the shield as well as dealing
with John Walker government's mentally
unstable pick for the title of cap the
show left us with a number of unanswered
questions that could well be addressed
in Captain America 4. especially with
the return of Carl lumbly's Isaiah
Bradley and Danny Ramirez as Joaquin
Torres we also expect to see Shira Haas
as the super-powered Israeli character
Sabra and Tim Blake Nelson as the leader
who was last seen in 2008 seeing
Incredible Hulk plus if Tyler will
return as the Incredible Hulk character
Betty Ross and Harrison Ford will step
into the role of Thaddeus Thunderbolt
Ross replacing the late William Hurt
Captain America New World Order hits
theaters on May 3rd 2024. everybody
knows the suicide squad DC super villain
group that goes on dangerous missions on
behalf of the US government while Marvel
has their own bunch of baddies too A
Team known as the Thunderbolts made up
of reformed tough guys the Thunderbolts
solved problems with violent methods and
now they're going to start cracking
skulls in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in June 2022 deadline announced that
Jake schreier would direct the upcoming
Thunderbolts flick set to start filming
in summer 2023. Trier has made a name
for himself directing Paper Towns and
Robot and Frank here he's teaming up
with screenwriter Lee sung Jin who
created Netflix's road rage dramedy beat
as for who's joining this version of the
team it was revealed at 2022's d23 that
we can expect to see Contessa Valentine
Tina Allegra de LaFontaine Elena bolova
the Winter Soldier Red Guardian U.S
agent Taskmaster and ghost they'll be
joined by Iowa at ebery of the Bear in
an undisclosed role as well as Steven
young of The Walking Dead in an unknown
part the deadline reports could play a
significant part to the MCU moving
forward we'll get to see these
anti-heroes in action when Thunderbolts
hits theaters on July 26 2024. over 15
years have passed since Wesley Snipes
last portrayed Marvel's half-human half
vampire hunter of bloodsuckers blade and
now the mantle is being passed to
two-time Academy Award winner mahershala
Ali Marvel's head honcho Kevin feige
told variety he's a perfect blade
because he's one of the greatest actors
working today because he's a huge fan of
our universe and a fan of that character
is a kind of dream casting that you
almost don't dare to dream that you can
actually do it but we had a couple of
meetings with him and very quickly
decided let's do this we won't see Ali
in action until late 2024 but we've
already heard from him the voice of the
new blade spoke to Kit Harington Dane
Whitman in the second eternals
post-credits scene indicating that his
story is going to be tied to Black
Knight going forward
sure you're ready for that Mr Whitman
originally basem Tariq of Mogul Mowgli
was set to direct however Tariq left the
film in September 2022 with Marvel
telling The Hollywood Reporter due to
continued shifts in our production
schedule basem is no longer moving
forward as director of Blade but will
remain an executive producer on the film
we appreciate basem's Talent on all the
work he's done getting blade to where it
is as a result blade has been pushed
back to September 6 2024 with white boy
Rick director Yan demolish taking over
behind the camera when the Joker hit
theaters in 2019 it quickly turned into
a pop cultural phenomenon earning over 1
billion dollars becoming the highest
grossing R-rated film ever and winning
Oscars for Joaquin Phoenix's performance
and its haunting score but that kind of
impact it was only a matter of time
before Arthur Fleck decided to cause a
little more chaos and now it looks like
he's getting back on stage for an encore
performance in June 2022 director Todd
Phillips announced on his Instagram that
there was a script for Joker 2 with the
title Joker furiado he also posted a
photo of Phoenix reading the screenplay
confirming the actor would be reprising
his oscar-winning role but where will
Joker seat will take us well we won't
know for sure until the film comes out
on October 4th 2024 but considering Lady
Gaga's playing Harley Quinn it looks
like things are going in a very
surprising Direction still even with so
many changes happening at DC's
headquarters the new Joker film will
remain separate from the rest of the DCU
and a little cinematic Corner that new
DC mogul's James Gunn and Peter saffron
are calling DC elseworld when Disney
took over Fox Kevin feige had to decide
what to do with the X-Men in Fantastic
Four franchises his first decision keep
Ryan Reynolds as the wildly popular
Deadpool surprisingly feige told
collider that Deadpool 3 will be the
first R-rated MCU film it will be rated
R and we are working on a script right
now and Ryan's overseeing a script Ryan
is a very busy very successful actor
we've got a number of things we've
already announced that we now have to
make but it's exciting for it to have be
gone again a very different type of
character in the MCU and Ryan is a force
of nature which is just awesome to see
him bring that character to life perhaps
most importantly Deadpool won't be the
only major mutant making an appearance
in September 2022 round announced on his
social media that Hugh Jackman would be
showing up for Deadpool 3. but we did
have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
and yes he'll be sporting those iconic
claws as he's reportedly coming back as
the Wolverine it'll be an absolute blast
seeing these two trading barbs and
beating up bad guys when Deadpool 3
opens on November 8th 2024. when Disney
completed its acquisition of fox in 2019
it seemed like only a matter of time
until the Fantastic Four showed up in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe then Kevin
feige confirmed that all new versions of
Mr Fantastic The Invisible Woman the
Human Torch and the thing were indeed
MCU bound when he spoke to variety a few
months later so what do we know about
the film in September 2022 it was
confirmed that Matt shackman of One
Division Fame would Helm the project so
far there have been no official casting
updates so even though John Krasinski
did play Reed Richards and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
fans shouldn't necessarily expect him
back his Multiverse of Madness director
Sam Raimi explained the fans had a dream
of who the perfect Reed Richards would
be and because this is an alternate
universe I think Kevin feige said let's
make that dream come true still with
Marvel's first family showing up in
phase six which will end with two
Avengers movies it seems they're going
to play a pretty significant part in the
unfolding Multiverse Saga we also know
the film which is set to debut on
February 14 2025 won't be a traditional
origin story after all that tale has
been told twice already instead
according to the Hollywood Reporter
we'll be jumping into a world where our
heroes already have their powers similar
to Peter Parker's introduction in
Captain America Civil War at one point
it looked like Henry Cavill was coming
back as Superman but then the Dwayne
Johnson film Black Adam was a
disappointment James Gunn and Peter
saffron took over the DCU and DC decided
to part ways with the British Man of
Steel gun split hair is at a January
2023 press conference where he unveiled
the future of the DCU saying we didn't
fire Henry Henry was never cast for me
it's about who I want to cast to
Superman and who do the filmmakers we
have want to cast and for me for this
story it isn't Henry so what is this new
story exactly well we know that it's
titled Superman Legacy that'll be
soaring into theaters on July 11 2025
and it will be kicking off a new chapter
of the DCU that gun is titled Gods and
Monsters this is a big one the true
beginning of the DCU this is called
Superman man Legacy we also know that
the movie which is being written and
directed by gun will be a return to a
more classic version of Clark Kent with
Peter Safran saying Legacy focuses on
Superman balancing his Kryptonian
Heritage with his human upbringing
Superman represents truth justice and
the American way his kindness in a world
that thinks of kindness as old-fashioned
with impressive box office numbers and
critical Acclaim it was only a matter of
time before Robert Pattinson would Don
the bat cow yet again after the success
of 2022's the Batman sure enough Warner
Brothers quickly confirmed a sequel that
would reunite the newest Bruce Wayne
with director Matt Reeves as for the
plots were still very much in the dark
though there have been some hints the
first film ended with a cameo by Barry
keog and his Joker while Reeves told
collider that a Mr Freeze story is a
possibility and Pattinson suggested to
Vanity Fair that he'd like to see the
cape Crusader face off against the court
of owls while we don't know the villain
we do know when we'll see the Batman
part 2 as announced by James Gunn and
Peter Safran the sequel will be part of
their elseworld slate and will hit
theaters on October 3rd 2025. mark your
calendars for 2025 marble fans because
that's when The Avengers will assemble
again a 2022's Comic Con it was
announced at Avengers the Kang Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars will officially
close out phase six and end the
sprawling Multiverse Saga at the moment
the cast and plot details for these
films are under lock and key although we
do know that Xiang Chi and the legend of
the 10 Rings director Destin Daniel
will Helm the Kang Dynasty well
it's rumored that a second director will
take on Secret Wars after he was set up
in Loki we all suspected that Kang would
most likely be the next big MCU threat
after all you don't earn a nickname like
the Conqueror because you're a nice guy
however we're not exactly sure how the
two Avengers films will tie together as
they're based on totally different
unconnected storylines in the comics
Kang Dynasty sees the Opera mentioned
big bad dominating Earth while Secret
Wars finds our favorite Heroes fighting
Dr Doom on the planet battle world after
a multiversal disaster Kang Dynasty is
scheduled to hit theaters on May 2nd
2025 and Secret Wars will be released on
May 1st 2026. we can't wait to see what
Kevin feige's plan is for the Avengers
we need a plan of attack I have a plan
attack
Colonel James Roadie Rhodes has long
been a supporting character in the MCU
Tony Stark's best friend and a key
member of The Avengers however he's
always taken a back seat to his more
famous colleagues but now a war machine
is getting the spotlight with his own
feature film armor Wars while we don't
100 know the film's plots we know that
it will involve the Iron Man Tech
winding up on the wrong hands and Roadie
will have to deal with the Fallout
originally armor Wars was meant to be a
Disney plus series but in September 2022
The Hollywood Reporter announced it was
instead heading to theaters though when
it will arrive is anyone's guess
according to collider Riri Williams was
also supposed to show up in the Disney
plus Series so we'll be interested to
see if she still plays a part in the
future thanks to an interview with star
Don Cheadle the one thing we do know
about the plot for sure is that the
events of the film will be set up in the
Disney plus series secret Invasion which
involves a Sinister scroll Invasion if
there's one thing James Gunn loves it's
a scruffy band of Misfits overcoming
their differences and teaming up for
some superhero action reproof just look
at Guardians of the Galaxy and The
Suicide Squad now gun is returning to
that winning formula with the authority
this time the heroes are far more
powerful and far more dangerous in
January 2023 gun and saffron announced
the new film based on the comics of DC's
Wild Storm imprint created by Warren
Ellis and Brian hitch The Authority
features a weird bunch of super people
such as the literally electric Jenny
Sparks and the violent Batman parody
midnighter unlike the Avengers of the
Justice League The Authority will do
whatever it takes to dispense their
version of Truth and Justice up to and
including assassinations and toppling
governments Gunn said at his 2023 press
conference one of the things that the
DCU is that it's not just the story of
heroes and villains not every film and
TV show is going to be about good guys
versus bad guy there are white hats
black hats and gray hats and in his
official teaser for the DCU gun said the
authority are a group of superheroes who
think the world is broken and they want
to fix it by any means necessary perhaps
more so than any other superhero
Hollywood loves casting and recasting
Batman in live action movies alone we've
seen seven different actors down the
back cowl and Patrol the shadowy streets
of Gotham City and now it looks like
we're gearing out for number eight with
the brave in the bowl a movie that will
introduce the new official DCU version
of the Caped Crusader and no this won't
be Ben Affleck or Robert Pattinson as
for the story it's based on Grant
Morrison's run with the character and
it's going to be a tale of a truly
dysfunctional Father's son Dynamic with
gun explaining in January 2023. this is
the story of Damian Wayne who's Batman's
actual son that he didn't know existed
for the first eight to ten years of his
life he was raised as a little murderer
and assassin he's my favorite Robin if
you're wondering little Damien's mom in
the comics is Talia al Ghul daughter of
Raz al Ghul which explains that whole
assassinate Peter saffron told slash
film that we can also expect to see
other members of the extended bat family
we feel like they've been left out of
the Batman stories in the theater for
far too long exactly which bat family
members that will be and who will play
them is still up in the air as is the
release date but with any luck bat might
and Ace the bat Hound will be coming to
theaters sooner rather than later for a
long time Supergirl was holding down her
corner of the arrowverse but DC fans
still wanted to see her on the big
screen and not the critically panned
then it was announced in February 2021
that Sasha kaje had been cast as Cara
zorrell for Andy musketes The Flash
which led many to speculate that
Supergirl would indeed soon be getting
her own movie whether or not kaje will
be playing Cara zorel and Supergirl
woman of Tomorrow remains to be seen But
in January 2023 gun and saffron
announced that the upcoming film will be
based on the popular
2021-2022 comic book series by Tom King
with King actually involved in the
project this Supergirl is a harder more
cynical version than previous
incarnations as Gunn explained we will
see the difference between Superman who
was sent to Earth and raised by loving
parents from the time he was an infant
versus Supergirl raised on a rock a chip
off of Krypton and who watched everyone
around her die and be killed in terrible
ways for the first 14 years of her life
and then come to Earth gun has also
promised that woman of tomorrow will be
a major sci-fi epic one of my favorite
comic book series from last year was Tom
King's run on Supergirl woman of
tomorrow and so we're going to turn that
into a big science fiction epic in the
comic we know that Supergirl is looking
for vengeance for her father's death and
with its gorgeous otherworldly
illustrations it's no wonder the comic
has been compared to the classic Neil
Gaiman series Sandman we'll see if the
film keeps that tone when it arrives at
a yet to be announced future date with
gun and saffron setting the DCU Down A
New Path they've also decided to divide
their storytelling into chapters similar
to how Kevin feige has been doing it
with Marvel Studios the first chapter
has been titled Gods and Monsters and
with Swamp Thing lurking around in the
bogs this is where the monsters come
into it created by lenween and Bernie
wrightston and repopularized by Alan
Moore Swamp Thing started out in his
original run as scientist Alec Holland
who wouldn't you know it was
accidentally turned into a hideous
vegetable monster in Moore's reboot the
character got darker more serious and
less human with a comic leaning more
into swamp things otherworldly side in
tune with nature and possessing the
ability to control plant life Swamp
Thing became a major player in the more
Supernatural side of the DC Mythos along
with characters like John Constantine
and Phantom stranger after landing a
1982 feature film by legendary horror
director Wes Craven and a critically
acclaimed 2019 TV show Swamp Thing
appears to be on track to help anchor
the new DC movie Universe gun and
saffron announced a project at their
January 2023 press conference reporting
that their new Swamp Thing movie would
as expected be in the horror genre
rather than pure super heroics Saverin
explained that they think this will make
the emerging DC film Universe more
interesting this is a film that will
investigate the dark origins of Swamp
Thing it's important to point out that
in these stories although interconnected
they're not all tonally the same each
set of filmmakers brings their own
aesthetic to these films and the fun has
seen how these totally different Works
match up in the future news that a black
actor was being sought for the role of
Superman and a new reboot broke way back
in early 2021 when it was revealed that
author journalist and comic book writer
tanahasi Coates was teaming with
producer JJ Abrams on the project Coates
told Shadow and act I look forward to
meaningfully adding to the legacy of
America's most iconic Mythic hero he
also expressed excitement at being
invited into the DC Universe but
according to the Hollywood Reporter his
Superman film won't be part of the DC EU
which has been effectively dismantled or
part of gun and saffron's new DC
Universe of films instead gun and
saffron have said the film will be
released under the DC elseworld spanner
the special title for non-dcu DC films
like Matt Reeves is the Batman and Todd
Phillips Joker The Hollywood Reporter
also dropped some big details about the
film including the identity of the main
character it has been speculated that
coach's film could potentially feature
the Barack obama-inspired Superman
Calvin Ellis but insiders told thr that
we're going to see a black cow L the
version of Superman audiences are most
familiar with the report also revealed
that the film might be a period piece
set sometime during the 20th century and
that JJ Abrams definitely won't be
directing The Hollywood Reporter wrote
Warners in DC are committed to hiring a
black director to tackle what will be
the first cinematic incarnation of
Superman featuring a black actor just
when the film will come out and who that
actor will be though remains a question
as Michael B Jordan a longtime fan
favorite candidate for the first black
Superman has seemingly ruled himself out
but hey Tracy Morgan is still available
uh is this for a roll
oh yeah yeah man the dust had barely
settled on the Epic Spider-Man no way
home when producers Kevin feige and Amy
Pascal jointly addressed the future of
Tom Holland's Peter Parker Holland was
joined on screen by former Spider-Man
Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield in his
third solo outing as Marvel's wall
crawler which smashed pandemic era box
office records and received widespread
critical Acclaim speaking to the New
York Times just days after the release
of Spider-Man no way home Pascal and
feige got candid about the future of the
franchise Amy and I and Disney and Sony
are talking about yes we're actively
beginning to develop where the story
Heads next which I only say outright
because I don't want fans to go through
any separation trauma like what happened
after far from home and will not be
occurring this time Pascal added that
the ending of Spider-Man no way home
gives him a lot of narrative
possibilities for the next film she
seemed to be playing at koi though
because previous comments from the
powers that be suggest the storyline has
already been settled on two weeks before
no way home even came out Pascal told
Fandango we are getting ready to make
the next Spider-Man movie with Tom
Holland and Marvel we're thinking of
this as three films and now we're going
to go on to the next three this is not
the last of our MCU movies and in
February 2023 Kevin feige elaborated on
the topic just a bit more telling ew all
I will say is that we have a story we
have big ideas for that and our writers
are just putting pen to paper out